welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul
aka the guy who doesn't do [ __ ] all day
falcon in the winter soldier episode 2
is finally here and throughout this
video we're going to be breaking down
all the ins and outs of its story
the marvel easter eggs you might have
missed and its comic book connections
before we get into the video though i
want to let you know that i've just
appeared on amazon prime video uk's new
show the screen test to discuss the best
world movie of all time
i went head to head with chief film
critic of the independent clarice
lockery and joe kimwin from the
cybernotes that's a really fun episode
that you should definitely check out
after this
anyway episode 1 followed sam and bucky
as they tried to adjust to life after
the blip
i forgot to mention last time that sam
getting turned down by a banker
is likely a reference to anchorman in
which ron burgundy said
the human torch was denied a bank loan
now there was huge outcry on the
internet last week when it was revealed
that fictional character tony stark
did not pay fictional characters the
avengers any wages
since then anthony mackie has come out
and said that all the heroes did their
odd jobs on the side
such as vision who made an only fans to
pay for that house
we were also introduced to captain white
privilege who looks like what happens
when you order a captain america costume
on wish
episode 2 has cap's side chicks finally
meeting up and thematically we get a lot
of developments between the two
both were given a mantle that they
didn't really want with sam's being
captain america
and bucky's being the winter soldier
though one is way worse than the other
you really get the feeling at points
that the pair could be trying to escape
their pasts and what was expected for
them
and i feel like the series will very
much be about them learning to accept
who they are
bucky of course will have the most
things to overcome as he was a villain
and arguably the character has one of
the most interesting arcs in the mcu
now before we get into the full
breakdown i just want to talk about
joaquin torres
and how he is in the comics time codes
will be below as always but make sure
you stick around until the end to see us
talking about where things could be
going
now in the source material torres was an
immigrant that came to the us with his
grandmother when he was six
because he'd seen firsthand what it was
like traveling to the country
the character used to go and leave food
and water along the mexican border for
people attempting to cross it
it was at this time that he was captured
by the sons of the serpents
who were working for the mad scientist
carl melis maylis had been kidnapping
people trying to cross into the country
and he experimented on them transforming
them into half-human animal hybrids
it was a weird run where sam was turned
into a wolf
and as for taurus he became a falcon i'm
not even kidding yeah that
that's what happened now sam eventually
turned back to normal but torres didn't
because he had been fused with sam's
bird red wing who possessed regenerative
capabilities due to being vampiric
anyway taurus slowly started to become
sam's partner and he took up the mantle
of falcon
now just in the same way that monica
rambo ended up having her superhero
origin in one division
i definitely think that this will be the
case with taurus too
though i can't see them carrying across
the vampire bird hybrid mutant man story
i think once sam eventually accepts the
role of captain america
that he too will become the falcon and a
in episode one he was even trying to
mess about with red wing
so i don't don't get too close to that
yeah might be a vampire it might be my
fist though hey that's that's a great
joke
now as for episode 2 we open with
ex-football captain turned captain
america
john walker returning to his high school
he's now doing the propaganda tour
that we saw steve participating in
during the first avenger
walker is joined firstly by who i'm
guessing is the girl he left behind
in order to perform his duty typically
in war movies
especially ones focused around the
second world war soldiers had to go off
and fight
whilst their partners stayed at home and
i very much get the feeling here that
walker has had to give up on any
relationships he could have
in order to do the job steve sacrificing
seeing peggy
was something he too had to do and it
does show that he and rogers are similar
even if he seems like a discount version
this scene is quite similar to the one
that steve had before the parades in his
first movie
and at one point walker even talks about
jumping on a grenade
which rogers did to prove he was worthy
joined by lamar hoskins aka battle star
these two become somewhat of a double
act that juxtaposes sam and bucky
in the comics hoskins and walker both
subjected themselves to a process
known as the power broker which we also
get lip service too in this entry
in the source material when walker first
came on the scene he used to stage
attacks to seem like a hero
and battle star helped to set these up
during our first breakdown we discussed
how we believe that walker was actually
working alongside the flag smashers in
order to carry out attacks
and battle star's arrival here
definitely helps to cement that
now like walker battle star has walked
the line between good and bad
but he has pretty much become a hero
much in the same way that walker has
his introduction is a really interesting
one and it's not the only big comic book
character who appears in this entry
now walker also discusses how he's sick
of the speeches and that he just wants
to do the job
hoskins says that this is the job and
this is playing on a line from sam
wilson captain america
in which sam discussed how he thought
everything would be parades and just
punching bad guys
however being a black man bearing the
shield he realized there were far more
politics involved than he'd ever
considered
and though this isn't reflected in
walker it's clear that captain america
must fit a certain narrative in order to
be accepted hoskins also mentions the
song star-spangled man with a plan
which is something that popped up in the
first avenger when steve went on parade
we hear a reworking of this for the high
school game with it being played by a
brass band whilst the cheerleaders hype
him up for his appearance on good
morning america
good morning america is actually tied in
heavily with the mcu
as it's often where clips debut and many
exclusives are dropped
we also see walker signing autographs
and even an action figure
these take months and months to create
making me think that the us have been
putting him through his paces for a
while
which is confirmed by the tests we hear
discussed in the interview
this shows they wanted nothing more than
fassam to hand over the shield
so they could give it to someone who
they deemed as being cap material
it was never about the shield being
displayed in the smithsonian and instead
all the government cared about was
pushing this propaganda machine
that they could easily control also
shout out to wyatt russo for completely
winning me wrong with his intro yeah
i did enjoy his performance i think he's
very much in the same vein as homelander
where he's great for the cameras
and he perfectly nails the persona that
one must have when representing what is
now
a brand the entire interview is just
part and parcel of taking on the role
but walker demonstrates that he's more
than capable when we hear his
achievements listed off
walker is the first person to receive
the medal of honor three times
and we watch his training in which he
seems more than adept at doing what's
needed
now an interesting part is that he
brings up tony stark and bruce banner
before stating that he doesn't have
money or super strength
personally i don't buy this and not only
does he have the budget of the us
military behind him
but i also believe that he's got super
soldier serum coursing through his veins
throughout the episode we see him doing
feats that would be very difficult for a
normal person to pull off
and the plot itself centers heavily
around this formula
thus i do think that he was experimented
on but due to the controversy
surrounding the serum because of the
winter soldier they've instead pretended
he's just a normal guy
so he's just just a normal guy like you
and me that can do
25 minute breakdowns in three hours
anyway cut to bucky watching tv and we
see him again
sitting on the floor last episode we
learned that this is where he slept
and it's a nod to the line in the winter
soldier in which sam talks about how
soldiers find it difficult
sleeping because steve and sam had soft
mattresses
they found it almost impossible to get
comfortable and this is also
something that's clearly reflected in
the buckster cut to sam heading out on a
mission
and we see him coming face to face with
the kappa's back propaganda that was
shown in the credits
it's everywhere in the military base
almost mocking him
and obviously sam didn't know that the
shield was going to be given to someone
as he would have preferred it just to
belong in the museum however he was lied
to
but due to the government's power
there's not much he can do
bucky arrives and berates him for giving
up the mantle and the two head out on a
mission
now bucky doesn't trust redwing because
as we know
the guy is old school according to
stereotypes of my grandma
not many 106 year olds know how to use a
computer
and this distrust of technology is seen
in him using a notepad
some of the cap rather than his phone
sam discusses the three big potential
threats that typically tend to pop up
and these include androids aliens and
wizards
the avengers have fought the first two
but i am struggling to think of when
they've clashed against a wizard
outside of ebony more however as this
takes place after the events of one
division
it could be hinting at how she's viewed
in the mcu as the last anyone heard of
her she was holding a town hostage
walker also mentions the big three so
it's likely now a military term
however we do learn that he's been
spying on sam through redwing
so maybe he dropped this line so that
they would find some commonality with
him
bucky talks about gandalf and how he
read the hobbit when it was first
published
meaning that the guy is officially a
nerd i love this whole argument
as he drops that he read it in 1937 and
if you've ever got into a dork debate
then you'll know something that's very
important is who discovered something
first
also who else googled the release date
just to make sure it was right i know i
did now the pair head out to munich
and have a soul-searching contest which
i hope becomes something that they do
every episode
bucky asks sam what his plan is and he
replies with
i have a plan before jumping out the
plane this is definitely playing on the
scene in the avengers in which cab asks
iron man what his plan of attack is
tony replies with i have a plan attack
before diving out
and i love how the scenes are mirrored
with the tech guy in super soldier one
repeating the same motif
you know it's like poetry they rhyme now
buggy jumps out of the plane without a
parachute
and this is something that we saw steve
doing at the start of the winter soldier
sam also mocks him and says he got it on
camera which could be a reference to
shuri doing it to t'challa in black
panther
though that might be a reach now the
pair head out to a disused factory
and we also see that sam has a red visor
on over his face
now you know who also has a red face
yeah red hulk
sampai's lip service to bucky spending
time in wakanda and becoming the white
panther
which bucky corrects to the white wolf
this was a nickname given to him in the
post-credits scene for bp
showing how he's adopted the moniker
they get caught and have to chase the
flag smashes
which allows bucky to bust out the super
fast running that we saw him pulling off
in civil war i don't know why
this always kills me whenever i see it
and i don't know why yet it just looks
so funny
now he makes it to the semi truck which
is where we're introduced to carly
morgenthau
now this is somewhat of a gender swap as
in the comics
flag smasher was called call this could
potentially be his daughter
or perhaps they've gone all out and
decided to change the character up
and paint her in a different light flag
smasher was always a villain
but here the group are seen as freedom
fighters and they're even helped by
regular people
referred to as robin hood they operate
much in the same
way that anonymous do and are a masked
organization that are attempting to take
down the corrupt structures of society
the group was snap survivors and from
what they say they were likely people
that were overlooked before the
cataclysmic event
with the population dwindled the
government probably put more focus on
things like homelessness and poverty
and thus they may have been treated
better however with everyone coming back
due to the blip
they've likely been forgotten about so
you can see where their anger arises
thus they are somewhat sympathetic
figures but one thing i can't forgive
is that cauli destroys red wing just
made me mad
and now i want them dead i want their
families dead
now a big fight breaks out on the truck
but walkers and hoskins arrive to save
the day
this is very similar to the comics in
which the pair used to set up attacks
and then shove out of the blue to show
how great they were now we also learned
that they tracked sam through redwing
showing that the government are indeed
keeping tabs on him sam could be a big
embarrassment for them as he's the
rightful captain america
and thus i think that walker is keeping
a close eye on the character
in sam wilson captain america when sam
started to make a name for himself
walker was actually hired to publicly
embarrass the character
which is what could be going on here
they pretty much sideline them and bucky
and sam end up on top of each other
making me think that joss whedon
probably directed this scene
walker also uses a gun which very much
juxtaposes the meaning of captain
america
in the comics when selecting what
iconography the character would have
the us tried to push him into using a
firearm but he settled on his shield
because he wanted to be seen as a
defender and not an attacker
this is why when sam uses his wings like
a shield you very much get the feeling
that he's fit for the role
whereas something is just not right
about walker
although i do accept that cap used guns
when he first started out
which this moment could be playing on
don't just don't at me yeah just don't
have me
now the flag smashers get away and they
pick simon bucky up on the road
where they discuss their ideals you get
the feeling that walker wants to really
work with them
but they don't trust him and therefore i
don't trust him
i know it's you that's been disliking
the videos now walker also somewhat
insults sam by suggesting that he could
be his wingman
meaning that he's pretty much putting
him in his place and letting him know
that's all he could ever beat
sam rejects this and aware that super
soldier serum is now out in the world
the pair head out to meet isaiah bradley
elsewhere we see the flag smashers
settling into a refuge
and carly gets a text message
threatening her life so the worst one
i've ever seen
as once the wife went out and told me to
take the pizza out of the oven and i
forgot
but it's it's almost as menacing as that
one now i'm guessing that this is the
power broker
that we get reference to at the end
however it could indeed be anyone
maybe they did a switch up and walker
isn't working with the flag smashes
and instead he just wants to take the
serum from them it's likely that he
wasn't the only candidate to be capped
and it is possible that the other flag
smashers were in the running
and that they were experimented on by
the government this would explain their
abilities and why they also want to get
even
but that's a very thin theory i just
want to go through all the possibilities
now they say after tomorrow there's no
going back meaning that the next episode
they will likely be launching an attack
it has been said that the show is going
to focus on a pandemic
and they may be using bio weapons which
is why they also had vaccines
either way lots of possibilities so let
me know your thoughts below
on the plane sam and bucky have a heart
to heart and throughout the episode we
learn that buck isn't mad
he's just disappointed he believes that
if steve was wrong about sam that he's
wrong about
him and it cements the doubts he has
within himself because of his past
now at isaiah's we also meet his
grandson eli
bradley in the comics he became a hero
known as patriot
who was part of the young avengers i
think that he will definitely end up
becoming a hero in the series too
and along with wiccan and speed ms
marvel and hawkeye
it seems like disney are forming the
group i would absolutely
love to see them and they could make for
a stop gap in between the avengers
movies
that allows us to you know keep keep the
threat high who knows
we may even get a disney plus series at
some point with them all coming together
and i think that this would work really
really well now through isaiah we see
that he has super soldier serum still
coursing through his veins
and is possible that it's passed on
genetically which would explain how his
grandson gets his powers
as for isaiah he has a long and sad
history
that very much comments on how black
soldiers are treated
his origins were heavily inspired by the
tuskegee syphilis
experiments which were a horrendous
point in human history
this involved the us government
pretending to treat syphilis and black
people
however they were simply administering
placebos in order to study the long-term
effects of the disease
this involved countless deaths and the
government simply enlisted people from
the black community to watch them die
and this is mirrored in bradley's story
after steve went missing they tried to
recreate the super soldier serum and
experimented on several black people in
order to make the formula once more
in the case of isaiah this worked and he
was made into captain america
however the project was swept under the
rug because the government didn't want
the public to believe that they were
giving black people any advantages
isaiah in the show talks about her
running with bucky and we also learned
that he managed to beat the character
taking his arm in the process the
government imprisoned bradley and ran
experiments on him tried to take his
blood and he was very much stripped of
his rights and kept secret
furious over this sam and bucky argue in
the streets
and the police arrive though they're
both as bad as each other
it's very clear that the police view
bucky as an innocent bystander
and see sam as the issue speaking to
their racial prejudice
even though there's a warrant out for
bucky's arrest they treat him far better
than they do sam
and it's arguably one of the biggest
bits of social commentary in the mcu
barnes hands himself in and at the
station we see how the police treat
walker
which juxtaposes what they did with sam
even though they were both captain
america at one point the pair are viewed
in different ways and the police want to
take selfies with one
whilst they will happily harass the
other bucky's therapist is brought in
and walker announces that he's pretty
much cleared him with the police
showing how much power and privilege he
possesses sam and bucky then go through
a therapy session
in which the pair at their differences
bucky has so much self-doubt in this
moment
and the acting by sebastian stan is
absolutely superb i think
leading to this being a great scene sam
really imparts that even if bucky
disagrees with him
it was his choice to do with the shield
what he wanted to and rather than having
people force him down a certain path
like they did with bradley
he'd rather make his own way outside
walker and hoskins try to get the pair
to team up with them
but they refuse and walker wants them to
stay out of his way
this is the first time we've seen his
darker side and it's setting up the path
in which he will likely become us
agent he definitely has a temper and
would be threatening if it wasn't so
close to something from the michael
jackson video beat it
in bratislava we see the power brokers
men descending on the flag smashes
now bratislava is a location in the
marvel universe that is home to a hero
known as the unicorn
located in slokovia this location also
seemed to pop up at the end of one
division
due to the markings on the cabin wonder
was in but we don't have that confirmed
yet
now what's interesting is that someone
gives them a warning that the brokers
are coming
and this could indeed be walker who
would be aware of the government's plan
a flag smasher remains behind to buy
them time and we see an agent telling
his boss they got away
the power broker in marvel is actually
the name of carl melis who we discussed
earlier on in the video the mad
scientist was not only linked in with
taurus
but he also gave us agent his strength
potentially explaining how the character
is able to do what he does
maelys is a madman that has caused lots
of issues in the marvel universe
so definitely expect to see him showing
up at some point especially
with how linkedin he is with the rest of
the characters that appear here
bucky realizes that zemo is the key to
everything and we occur to him in his
cell
now an interesting detail is that
there's a door panel that looks like hal
from 2001 a space odyssey
semo will clearly be a big part of the
next episode and we know from the
trailers that he does get free
he was also on bucky's list so expect to
see the character making right with him
we also saw in the trailer bucky
emptying a gun on him meaning that
zemo probably tries to use the mind
control words
but he shows that he no longer has power
over him now we didn't cover the credits
last week but there are some notable
things in them that i thought i'd go
over here
this isn't scene by scene but it should
go over the main things that were
revealed
firstly we get lip service paid to the
enhanced humans act
to the backdrop of captain america
propaganda this discusses the
classification of the experiments
which were carried out by thaddeus ross
in the comics ross was connected to the
group the thunderbolts who will likely
show up in the mcu at some point
the character also experimented on
himself to create the red hulk
and thus this enhanced humans act could
be setting that up
we also learn that the flag smashers
carried out an attack in tokyo
which we know is to stabilize after the
snap because hawkeye had to unleash
vigilante justice there
there's also a node to the brass monkey
saloon which is a bar that's a local
madrapa
and a picture of the illuminati symbol
in the comics the illuminati was a group
made up of some prominent members of the
avengers
x-men inhumans and jay-z there's also
the nod to the experimentation on black
people that was carried out by the
government after steve was frozen
when cat was put on ice several black
recruits were put forward for testing
whilst the government attempted to
recreate the super soldier formula
now as for the episode itself i
absolutely love how much balance there
is in this show
you can have your action scenes one
minute and then in the next have some
close-up character studies
that really develop and flesh out the
psychology of those within the cast
i have a confession to make yeah i've
been pretty preoccupied with watching
zack snyder's justice league six times
this week
but this show snuck up on my left out of
nowhere and i really enjoyed these 50
minute long looks at the characters
overall another great episode i couldn't
believe that next week we're gonna be
halfway through the series
i feel like pure [ __ ] i just want the
mcu back
and hopefully things stay at this level
of quality going way into the future
if you're enjoying the video then please
hit the thumbs up button and make sure
you subscribe to the channel for
breakdowns on the series week by week
before we get into a cool first look at
sam's captain america costume
i also want to give a thank you for
getting the channel to the point that i
was asked to be on the new movie
broadcaster screen test
on prime video uk's youtube channel
hosted by that handsome devil jack
howard
the show has three guests fighted out
every week to decide
which movie a tv show is the best of the
best in its genre
we talked save in private ryan which was
my choice the hill locker and apocalypse
now
and broke down each movie with their
most memorable scenes
what had the biggest impact and a lot
more it was a really really fun episode
and
you need to go over there right now and
say i won otherwise i'm gonna kick off
yeah i
swear god yeah i'm gonna kick off don't
make me do it now the episode's released
every wednesday at 5 p.m
and it's on the prime video uk channel
which is linked in the description right
below
if you want to listen to it while you
walk it's also on amazon music
or wherever you get your podcasts at so
i'll see you over there after this
okay so if you are following our one
division breakdowns then you'll know
that the costumes of wicked and speed
were leaked because of some funko pop
releases
a similar sort of thing has happened
with sam wilson's new suit
which if you don't want anything spoiled
then i recommend that you turn off
in five four three two one romeo done
okay so this was posted on the disney
store and it shows the marvel select
figure for fat wits
with sam donning his white red and blue
costume the name of the figure is also
captain america
cementing that sam will end up in the
role during the series
we often go on about how marvel will
need to keep the mcu movies accessible
to people who only watch the films
and therefore everything in these
spin-offs will likely end up the way
that things were at the end of end game
so sam will become cap and then you can
just go from
end game into the next avengers movie
without having to learn about the
subplot in which he became iron man for
a bit
as for the costume itself it looks
extremely similar to his uniform in the
comics
and i absolutely love how they've
managed to recapture the look of that
there's also the shield that comes as
part of the pack so it's pretty likely
that sam will end up holding it on his
arm
as he flies like a falcon let my spirit
carry me
come on anyway that pretty much sums
everything up and obviously i'd love to
hear your thoughts on the episode so
make sure you comment below and let me
know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
through on the 31st of march in which
you're giving away three copies of a
marvel 4k boxer of your choice all you
have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of the best
easter eggs in zack snyder's justice
league which will be linked on screen
right now
i've also part of the episode of the
screen test if you want to see me
debating why saving private ryan is the
best war movie ever made
and i'd massively appreciate the support
as it opens up a lot more opportunities
like that
anyway without the way thank you for
sticking through the video i've been
paul i'll see you next time
take care peace